ex buonasera a tutti io sono paolo
vincere si iscrivono di viaggi di
ristoranti e di ristoranti che fanno
viaggiare non penso sia un caso che
ludovica presentando il tè di oggi
parlando di tradizione innovazione sia
partita dalla bagna cauda e da una
citazione che senza nulla togliere al
buon carlin restituirei al vero
proprietario che oscar wilde
sai che la tradizione non è altro che un
innovazione ben riuscita
dico che non mi sembra un caso perché
pochi altri argomenti abbracciano
tradizione innovazione se ne servono in
ugual misura al pari del cibo e della
ristorazione che del cibo e la punta di
diamante quindi giusto per
destabilizzarvi partirei dalla
preistoria e cominciando appunto con
l'uomo che si muove sulla terra è uno
dei primi bisogni primari che deve
andare a soddisfare è proprio quello di
nutrirsi quindi nella prima fase
ovviamente si limita a raccogliere non
si guarda intorno
utilizza la vista che è uno degli
strumenti più utili anche per nutrirsi
anche se molto spesso non ce ne rendiamo
conto fin che non parliamo con un cieco
quindi si aiuta con la vista e decide in
maniera arbitraria quali cibi secondo
lui sono commestibili edibili e quali
invece è bene tenere lontano in seconda
battuta arriva l'esperienza non tanto la
sua quanto quella degli altri perché
quando un australopiteco si avvicina e
una fogliolina di cicuta e la mangia
vedendola morire gli altri probabilmente
non limiteranno e quindi inizia a
formarsi una sorta di coscienza di
inconscio di cultura collettiva che
porta l'uomo habilis poi a cominciare
avere qualche piccolo strumento per
tritare per migliorare la propria
esperienza una volta che ha raccolto
l'ingrediente ma la vera innovazione il
vero cambiamento arriva col homo erectus
che ci mette circa un milione e mezzo di
anni prima di scoprire e padroneggiare
il fuoco ma a quel punto davvero cambia
perché nel momento in cui lui prende una
sua costata di mammut e la poggia su un
fuoco e la cuoce dandole una trasforma
se ne chimica per la prima volta sta
cucinando almeno come lo intendiamo noi
in questo senso possiamo già immaginare
che nello strutturarsi di una piccola
società minima come quella che l'uomo
stabiliva agli albori
ovviamente ci fossero le donne per lo
più adibite a cucinare perché l'uomo
andava a caccia e quindi c'era bisogno
di suddividere i compiti in un secondo
momento però man mano che le società si
fanno più complesse e nascono le prime
vere e proprie civiltà
ecco che chi sa cucinare comincia vero
ruolo sociale diverso non è più solo
qualcuno che semplicemente scalda degli
ingredienti di trasforma in
qualcos'altro ma molto spesso è uno
strumento sociale utilizzato da chi ha
potere per dimostrare quanto ne sa
perché se io sono il re il capo tribù un
dittatore o anche solo un capo clan
voglio far vedere agli altri sia interni
al mio gruppo sia esterni qualora
vengano in vita da me quanto io sia
importante e per farlo possa servirmi di
uno strumento semplicissimo che la
cucina perché tutti sempre mangiamo ogni
giorno questa almeno chi può farlo
purtroppo in questo senso
come potete immaginare man mano che la
società va a strutturarsi il peso cresce
continua a crescere continua a crescere
i pochi di corte diventano dei
personaggi importanti ne traiamo
cronache assiri e babilonesi che ci
raccontano per filo e per segno i
banchetti cosa è stato mangiato cosa no
e soprattutto si concludono con un
tributo al gran maestro di cerimonia
colui che ha cucinato proseguiamo ancora
e si arriva dalle corti direttamente al
sistema nobiliare e qui ancora la
battaglia si fa più ardua perché non
solo io devo dimostrare qualcosa a un
sovrano in visita ma io marchesi di
gresy quando ho il conte di pompigna t
che viene da me voglio fargli vedere che
mio poco più bravo del suo e sarà già un
grande
ecco che gli do ma in questo senso la
cucina si sta sviluppando in un modo
esclusivamente dedicato alla nobiltà a
chi può permettersi di avere un cuoco
che vive in casa la ristorazione in quel
momento non esiste e ristoranti non
esistono esistono le taverne e locande
quelle che di solito si vedono nei film
nei romanzi dedicati al medioevo ma sono
di fatto dei punti di ristoro collocati
in crocevie importanti o in snodi di
strade che collegano tutta europa e dove
si entra si mangia un piatto cucinato
dalla moglie dell'oste si beve un po si
va a dormire si riparte è più una casa
aperta che una ristoro e un ristorante
quando nasce il ristorante c'è una data
precisa
almeno della causa scatenante di questa
nascita che il 14 luglio 1789 la
rivoluzione francese perché vi che
cambiano le regole
è lì che di colpo ogni cuoco di francia
si trova disoccupato gli hanno tolto
tutti i datori di lavoro qualcuno
comincia in una sorta di diaspora
viaggiare per l'europa e cercare altre
corti dove andare a cucinare ma la gran
parte non sa cosa fare qui però subentra
un altro fattore sociale perché la
borghesia
anche se ha voluto debellare la nobiltà
di fatto cerca di somigliare il più
possibile e quindi ambisce a mangiare
tutte quelle cose che prima erano solo
dei nobili e invece adesso sarà un bene
disponibile a chiunque quindi alcuni
cuochi provano un po come esperimento
aprire dei ristoranti e la cosa funziona
funziona moltissimo
solo che c'è un problema con questa fase
abbiamo detto che solo i pochi francesi
sono svincolati perché nel resto
d'europa le monarchie continuano a
funzionare nel resto del mondo non c'è
mai stato questo sistema
quindi cosa succede che la cucina la
gran chiusi in che inizia a viaggiare ea
diventare riconosciuta come grande è
solo francese ed è un modello ben
preciso ed è un modello che si basa
ancora su questo nel questa necessità di
stupire e di far banchettare delle
persone anche a scapito della loro
salute
perché un re non si preoccupa di quanto
ci mette a smaltire il brasato si
preoccupa che sia buono quindi arriviamo
dal 1789 al ventesimo secolo con dei
ricettari immutati noi andiamo a
prendere chi ha codificato queste cose
auguste escoffier altri grandi francesi
e le ricette del 1821 e quelle del 1921
sono identiche per attuare un
cambiamento vero
ci vogliono un gruppo di cuochi francesi
nel 1972 michel gerhard paul bocuse
alain chapelle rose emergenti questi
sono solo dei ragazzi all'epoca che si
trovano un tavolo e di calma perché ne
dobbiamo sottostare queste regole
stabilite da qualcuno che non conosceva
la nostra società non conosceva il
nostro modo di vivere e nemmeno
conosceva gli elementi a nostra
disposizione
stabiliamo delle nuove regole per
esempio alleggeriamo i piatti prima di
tutto andiamo a togliere tutto il sapore
e il gusto in eccesso andando a togliere
dei grassi poi è vero dobbiamo strà
cuocere tutto perché la gente abituata e
se noi invece è leggerissimo anche le
cotture e ci limitassimo a sbollentare
gli ingredienti ma mantenendo così il
loro vigore è quella che la loro natura
a questo punto rispetto a prima quando
stufava moero vivevamo tutto dobbiamo
anche avere molta più cura selezione per
gli ingredienti perché altrimenti si
nota nel momento in cui tutte diverse te
li servono di solo che messi insieme
tutti questi dettami qualcun altro da
loro un etichetta che poi demonizzare a
questo movimento e capirete subito
nouvelle cuisine la nouvelle cuisine
in realtà nasce con questi intenti puri
poi viene scimmiottata e resa
macchiettistica da tanti tanti cuochi in
giro per il mondo fino a diventare il
simbolo dire i micro piatti serviti ed
il mantra di chi attacca nouvelle
cousine usciti di lì si va a mangiare la
pizza questa classica ed è legittimo
in questa fase la francia prende ancora
più egemonia nel mondo della cucina e
naturale perché sono loro che hanno
stabilito sia
le vecchie che quelle nuove quindi
sembra che il destino sia semplicemente
quello della gran chiusi infranse e
tutti gli altri a rincorrere a dare un
assist involontario in questo senso a un
cambiamento è ancora un francese alain
ducasse è un guascone che decide di
affrontare la vita e nella maniera molto
diretta dopo che sopravvive a un
incidente aereo di cui è l'unico
sopravvissuto perde un occhio rimane un
anno a letto e aveva un ristorante
all'epoca che deve gestire a distanza
quindi si rende conto che si può fare
che il cuoco non deve più per forza
stare ai fornelli sei stato un bravo
maestro sei stato capace di fare
intendere a tutti i suoi sottoposti
quei passaggi fondamentali per
riprodurre la sua cucina lui può essere
ovunque anche in un letto d'ospedale
guarisce e dice ma allora se è così
perché non replico il mio ristorante in
giro per il mondo non solo più il fuoco
che vuole stare lì al pass a controllare
ogni piatto che esce io voglio che le
mie idee
la mia cucina tutto quello che io ho
scoperto e ricercato viaggi insieme a
dei ragazzi che ho formato io che
diventi nomi e ambasciatori nel mondo
luca si inventa il ruolo di cuoche
imprenditore perché è così importante
perché svincola il cuoco da quelli che
erano i suoi dettami svincola il cuoco
dal ruolo di cuciniere e basta lo rende
qualcos'altro
quindi come dicevo da uno spunto ma per
rompere davvero gli schemi
abbiamo bisogno di arrivare in spagna
dieci anni dopo da quello che è il di
chef della cucina ovvero ferran adrià
per andria è diventata della cucina
molecolare quindi di nuovo in prima
istanza colui che ha iniziato a usare
sfere arginati spume e tutte quelle
quindi elementi chimici che poi trovati
in giro per il mondo usati da persone
meno furbi di lui hanno portato la gente
a odiare tutti questi elementi
in realtà quello che insegna tra andrea
non è usate più sfere non è cucinare
piatti assurdi e bellissimi anche se i
suoi spesso lo sono e sono provocazioni
ma lui svincola il cuoco dall'obbligo di
cucinare qualcosa che sia esclusivamente
buono e dice sì è importante che sia
buono ma perché è un piatto
può essere un medium per un messaggio se
lo può essere una lettera se lo può
essere un film se lo può essere una
canzone perché io non posso dirti
qualcosa con un piatto chi me l'ha
proibito e quindi si mette a provocare
apre le menti dice giocate con le vostre
regole lasciate stare i francesi
lasciate di perdere le fate quello che
volete
questo messaggio attecchisce per un
adrian fa proseliti in tutto il mondo
ragazzi che vanno da lui in catalonia
studiano le sue i suoi concetti dopo di
che tornano a casa e li applicano alle
loro culture
uno di quelli che l'ha fatto senz'altro
meglio e in questo senso poi ha portato
un'altra rivoluzione e rené redzepi un
ragazzo di origini albanesi cresciuto in
danimarca
chiaramente danese 6 domandate a lui che
impara ad atri a quelle che sono le sue
regole d'oro dopo di che torna in
danimarca e dice certo che non solo ha
ragione ma se io mi metto qui a
copenaghen a cucinare grande cucina
francese perché qualcuno ovunque sia nel
mondo deve venire da me a mangiare
allora a parigi andrà a lione andrà
amarsi ne andrà in francia ma se io
invece cucina la mia terra e racconto la
mia storia chiunque sia interessato a
scoprirla è costretto a venire da me in
questo senso
ecco in questo senso redzepi inizia a
raccontare non solo la sua storia ma la
storia di una comunità
la difficoltà maggiore sta nel fatto che
sia danese e quindi non esista una
cultura gastronomica in danimarca si
mangiano patate aringhe pane stop come
fa lui quindi a far viaggiare la gente
per andare da lui inventa una cultura
gastronomica e lo fa partire dalla
cultura punto si chiede cosa mangiavano
i suoi antenati si chiede cosa mangia se
la gente in danimarca 500 anni prima lo
recupera usa la tecnica imparata da dria
e la trasforma in piatti che non
somigliano a null altro al mondo la
gente da tutto il pianeta comincia a
viaggiare comincia a raggiungerlo
comincia andare a vedere che cosa sta
facendo rese p e lui apre una quindicina
di ris
anche ai suoi ragazzi a copenaghen
copenaghen oggi è una delle tre capitali
mondiali del gusto
dieci anni fa era il simbolo del mangiar
male nel mondo questo lo ha fatto lui
esclusivamente rouyet e foglie muschi
formiche perché lui dicesse ho bisogno
di aggiungere acidità un piatto io non
ho i vostri limoni di amalfi o le
formiche col loro acido formico in
questo senso qua invece un altro
esponente simile virgilio martinez un
ragazzo che sta a lima e cuci dalla
foresta pluviale amazzonica perché di
uomo dice ok il fois gras eccezionale lo
puoi mangiare dove vuoi
se tu vieni da me mangi in un piatto 18
varietà di mais diverse e non ti sto
solo facendo un piatto buono vi assicuro
che lo è ti sto raccontando la
biodiversità del mio paese ed è il modo
più efficace di fartelo capire facendo
per assaggiare semplicemente l'italia in
questo senso ha avuto forse quello che
l'esponente più importante del post
adria che è colui che poi ha disegnato
le regole per un altro cambiamento
ancora che massimo bottura massimo
bottura ha avuto la fortuna di lavorare
sia con due caschi che d'archi con
andrea
quindi hai imparato il meglio di
entrambi i sistemi dopo di che torna a
modena e decide di farsi portatore dei
valori della tradizione italiana
ma lui dice giustamente se io voglio che
la gente nel mondo mi ascolti gli devo
prendere il meglio del passato leggerle
in chiave critica e portarlo nel futuro
perché se io ancora faccio le
tagliatelle al ragù di mia nonna ai
tedeschi la prima volta magari
apprezzano anche poi quando si accorgono
dell'apporto calorico e dei grassi
cominciano già i primi dubbi bottura per
esempio prende
il parmigiano reggiano e si chiede come
raccontarlo a chi non sia italiano per
noi è abbastanza ovvio per tutti a tutti
i livelli anche chi non va mai al
ristorante sa che un parmigiano a
seconda che la di stagionatura è diverso
perché a seconda di quanta pazienza se
ha avuto di quanto tempo si è lasciato
abbandonato in una cantina quel prodotto
prende una forma un sapore diverso
ma come puoi raccontarlo a un americano
e un russo a un arabo a persone che non
hanno questo tipo di cultura e non hanno
nessuna conoscenza di questo prodotto
come puoi raccontare il passare del
tempo attraverso un boccone
non è facile ma bottura decide di
prendere 5 forme di parmigiano con
stagionatura e diverse e ognuna di esse
applica una tecnica avanzatissima
appresa nelle cucine di adria che lo
valorizzino al meglio quindi tu avrai
nell'arco di un solo boccone cinque
passaggi diversi che dimostrano come il
tempo può cambiare le cose a modena
nella sua città un altro piatto che va
in questa direzione che fortunamente
appunto è la parte croccante della
lasagna o addirittura il pensiero supera
di parecchio quello che poi el
esecuzione perché di fatto lui prende
una lasagna e le toglie tutto a parte
una piccola spicco lo strato di pasta
croccante una besciamella molto
alleggerita e ora gounod
ma perché lo fa lui non interessa
raccontarti nella sagna è un americano
di nuovo in visita a modena per qualche
giorno non può far mangiare all'interno
di un menù una lasagna allora lui dice
io voglio raccontarti una cosa sai qual
è il momento migliore per ogni bambino
italiano
quando la madre prepara le lasagne
quando tirate fuori dal forno le
appoggia sul tavolo lui 4 arriva e ruba
un angolino l'angolino croccante quindi
questo non essere un piatto che racconta
i prodotti che racconta la storia di un
di un paese ma è un piatto che racconta
una memoria collettiva nostra penso che
a chiunque sia capitato almeno una volta
nella vita di rubare l'angolo delle
lasagne della madre a questo punto
bottura è il primo come dicevo a fare un
discorso ancora più alto perché dice
bene adesso abbiamo spostato la cucina
siamo passati da beni materiali che
quindi non potevano viaggiare a beni
immateriali idee che quindi posso far
viaggiare
appunto perché devo limitarmi a parlare
di cibo ea sfruttare tutta la mia fama
solo amia unico vantaggio per portare
gente nel mio ristorante quando posso
provare a comunicare qualcosa di molto
più grande al mondo e all attenzione del
mondo perché come professionista me la
sono meritata
in questo senso la vita a una serie di
progetti che sono i riflettori il primo
il refettorio ambrosiano nato durante
expo in un quartiere povero di milano in
greco dove bottura prende un refettorio
della caritas chiede a una serie di
amici e designer di renderlo molto bello
dopo di che chiama tutti i migliori
cuochi del mondo a turno adriatica se le
zie pi tutti gli altri a cucinare con le
derrate in avanzo che arrivano ogni
giorno da expo prima di essere buttate
in quei prodotti quasi scaduti che non
dovrebbero essere più utili ed il iv a
cucinare ogni giorno per cento indigenti
a questo punto bruttura non sta
semplicemente dando un servizio a quelle
100 persone ma sta facendo riflettere
una comunità quella della gastronomia
mondiale su quanto cibo sprechiamo ogni
giorno e se voleva vedere i dati spara
di miliardi di tonnellate un po di
magone viene intanto lui sfrutta la sua
luce per buttarla da quell'altra parte
replica il progetto siccome ha
funzionato a rio durante le olimpiadi
con le ferrate in avanzo dal villaggio
olimpico
adesso appena aperto a londra sta
aprendo a parigi nelle bandiere ea new
york nel bronx e sta riuscendo a
propagare un'idea attraverso quello che
lui ha fatto tutta la vita dei piatti
nient'altro
un altro poco italiano tre stelle molto
importante niko romito a castel di
sangro in abruzzo arrivato all'apice ha
deciso di rallentare il suo lavoro
professionale
per quanto riguarda i riconoscimenti e
tutto il resto
per dedicarsi un paio d'anni allo studio
di piatti e menù unicamente dedicati i
pazienti degli ospedali perché lui dice
è possibile che uno è malato ha dei
problemi viene ricoverato e poi si trova
molto spesso a mangiare del cibo che
oltre a essere triste e stracotto cotto
male e quindi perde ogni capacità
nutritiva perde tutte le sue
caratteristiche organolettiche
perché dobbiamo farlo quando invece con
un po di tecnica
io grande poco quindi io che faccio un
lavoro per pochi per quei pochi che
possono spendere 300 euro una sera io
posso andare a cambiare la vita di
moltissime persone e farlo attraverso
quello che ho maturato in tutta la mia
vita quindi in chiusura
siamo partiti dall omo erectus e siamo
arrivati a un cuoco che prova a cambiare
il cibo degli ospedali attraverso dei
complicati sistemi di forno a vapore può
sembrare molto forzato però quello che
io volevo dire è che ogni volta che
nella cucina noi accusiamo qualcosa di
essere troppo innovativo e adria per
esempio è stato per anni accusato di
stregoneria è andato anche a striscia la
notizia in italia su grandi scandali e
bene che ripensiamo a quel povero ma
lectus che per primo cose una costata di
mammut e di fu dato del pazzo quando
invece aveva cambiato la storia
dell'uomo
grazie
[Applauso]